guys like a satoshi nakamoto of boring
businesses so Shawn puts us on here as
Billy of the week mark Leonard
you wanna we sometimes do this
billionaire of the week so the Billy of
the week is mark Leonard constellation
software so I had heard about this for a
few people because they do something
that you know we had Andrew Wilkinson on
here and he buys internet businesses and
sort of has this conglomerate of small
internet business that he's collected
that are now you know let's call it a
hundred million dollars worth or maybe a
little more a little less and that's a
fantastic success so this guy mark
Leonard did that like he's Andrews daddy
you know like he his company's worth
thirty 1 billion dollars what they do is
they buy software companies and they
roll them up sort of and they're they
try to be a perpetual owner so they're
not like they're not private equity
where they're doing a leveraged buyout
and trying to flip you know kind of skin
it and flip it or whatever they tried to
just own the thing for a long period of
time and had the cash flows and so what
I like about this guy what I thought was
cool was this guy's like a Satoshi
Nakamoto of boring businesses so he
nobody knows about this guy you
can't find a photo of them wait what's
that reference the Bitcoin guy yeah you
just don't know a lot about I guess so
so this guy you can't find photos of
them he doesn't do public appearances he
doesn't really talk he writes his annual
letter and you know but so I was reading
like kind of the definitive thing about
him because I wanted to learn and it's
like all we know is this guy's born in
1956 maybe in South Africa maybe in
England I was like what the we
don't even know where this guy's from
and you know he's wrote on his bio he's
like he was a VC and but before that he
said I was a banker evaluator a Mason a
gravedigger a dog handler a bouncer a
sapper and wind energy researcher I
particularly enjoyed the bouncing but an
early retirement was necessary so I
loved it that I don't know anything
about this guy but what we came love and
I think half those are like a joke but
here's their business so they buy in the
early on they buy they bought businesses
that were you know two to four million
dollar acquisition target so very small
acquisition which is which is on paper
you would say that's asinine my own yeah
tough change you know okay
you know a small ball but small balls
turn into sort of big league returns and
so you know this data is out of date now
because when the article I was reading
was like hey this guy has you know done
really well they did last year they had
1.2 billion in sales 20% margins they're
doing 10 to 20 acquisitions a year and
at that time the market camp was 5
billion I looked at it while I was
reading the article it's now 31 billion
and so if you're just invested my guys
it they have a thirty 1 billion dollar
valuation and only one point to and that
was the old one when they were at five
billion market cap now they're at thirty
1 billion a market so you know if the
ratio sort of held held the same it'd be
whatever six seven billion in sales we
can see we can see what it is now but I
love that this guy's mysterious I love
dude it's probably it's only it's three
billion their sales were only three
billion dollars a lot of money but
that's not a got a good little I wonder
I wonder why it's going on such the run
up because you can see the stock chart
it's like you know it's going up like
crazy and then they can use that money
for for acquisitions and this guy he
writes these annual letters that are
actually pretty interesting so like if
you're like me you I like to read Bezos
his annual letter I like to read Warren
Buffett's annual letters this guy is a
new one I'm adding to the sort of
arsenal of annual letters and he has a
lots of really interesting sort of views
on business and none of which are like
totally groundbreaking but he does
something that I think most people fail
to do which is the same thing Warren
Buffett does which is take a very simple
principle then everybody would nod their
head and agree with and then like
actually stick to it and do it for like
40 years
and that's like a winning formula most
people you know nod their head and then
go do some other and they get their
lack of discipline and lack of focus and
so I also like you know trying to read a
little bit more about the company and
you know they have sort of a focus on
what they call vertical software so
they'll go for like within one vertical
hour sorry they looked at this and hey
some companies are horizontal like a
slack every company can use slack as a
messaging service and slack will be a
multi-billion dollar company but what
about all these vertical things that are
like better software specifically
tailored software for uh you know what
if you're a golf club you need to manage
bookings T times memberships and
whatever else every golf club you will
pretty much use whatever the bests off
they'll pay for it every month reliably
and they'll never churn so they'll buy
like that clubhouse software they'll buy
healthcare software public transit
software law software and that's been
their focus I don't know if that's a
change over time but when I was reading
about them they try to consolidate
vertical market software which I thought
was a pretty interesting approach what
do you think of this guy I love it I'm
reading about what you have here so I
love doing these things and I love that
but what he's doing and I actually I'm
gonna bring up a different point and I
don't want to address it yeah but I want
to ask your opinion of it in a second
but more so what I'm interested in is
and I I don't want to refer to like
things I tweeted that sounds super lame
but I was tweeting earlier about how I
hired an operator so basically Adam Ryan
works at the company and he kind of
handles a lot of the operational stuff
and I work sometimes down in the weeds
sometimes higher vision stuff and it's
hard finding someone who's competent to
run a business and so if this if this
guy if he might have I just say I many
companies he has it could be like 200
right so I don't know if they're not or
if they keep the existing management or
if they replace them I'm not I'm not one
percent sure what they do I'm sure
there's some some mix and blend there
one thing I saw that was interesting was
so they like Berkshire Hathaway the
execs of the companies do not get share
options as their compensation which
basically you know incentivizes you just
boost the share prices as you as much as
you can which is often somewhat
short-term so instead they take you know
75% of their after-tax bonus and they
can buy shares on the open market and
then those shares are held in escrow for
four years so if the shares if the stock
is overvalued because they are sort of
temporarily pumping you know enthusiasm
energy or doing buybacks or whatever
they're buying overvalued stock and so I
don't know if this is perfect because
maybe the other thing happens where they
actually you know when they're about to
buy they sort of you know bad news dips
the state share price temporarily they
could buy it on the discount so I'm not
sure if any incentive system is perfect
but I thought it was interesting that
they've thought through how should we
compensate everybody and and not sort of
follow the traditional playbook
so I want to dig in more I've only just
scratched the surface of this guy I
think there's a lot to learn here but I
wanted to bring it up because I think
it's very interesting and I like that
he's a sort of mysterious character I
think that adds to it
[Music]